as a kid
of the 90s who was mighty obsessed with
look who's talking now
i do have to ask you while you were
playing
bob in this movie were you channeling
rocks at all yeah
no i i i i just i kind of
approach every role in a different you
know
a new uh you know i've done a lot of
animated movies and
lorax and whatever i just uh
you know uh i don't know what the lorax
was not a dog but
uh you know i played uh you know in
hercules
i was uh what do you call the the
yeah him philip tatis and
so i just approached character like i do
a normal
like an everyday character bob and the
one and only ivan
was very footloose fancy free thought he
had the world on a string
could do anything he wants get by with a
hot dog a
leftover piece of pizza you know but he
realizes
that what is really important is to have
the friendship
and have a friend and have a place to be
and have a
solid family around them whether it's
like an intimate family or
you know how close and then what wasn't
bad that i had helen mirren upstairs
my poodle crush i could i could i could
uh
i love going around uh for that too
uh so it's it i just i just go for it
you know whether
you know i'm falling out of a window and
sunny coming out of a couch naked
or uh playing bob the dog in the in the
one and only ivan it's really a lot of
fun
can you tell me a little bit about
working with thea
on this because you've had so much
animation experience and you've worked
with some of the best of the best as far
as directors go in the industry but she
was telling me earlier that she had
never
directed someone doing a voice
performance in the booth so
did you find that her fresh set of eyes
came in handy
thea and i have worked together before
we worked on she directed a
play i did on on the west end
uh the sunshine boys neil simon play so
i know her i know her as a
uh what she is has to offer as a
director and it's really
she's one of the best that i've ever
worked with she's really detailed
really cares about what she's doing
knows
exactly what she wants is able to
communicate it
so it was it was a lot of fun because
we did take after take after take
and in in this situation
uh there's uh there was a
a great of uh there are parameters
they have to work in but there was a
freedom too
and i think uh coming from
uh the the solid base that she comes
from
uh of theater and dealing with actors
knowing how to talk to actors and how to
communicate what she wants
uh it was a big plus before we wind down
here
i did want to ask you having worked with
colin on dumbo
do you guys keep in touch and did you
happen to give him any advice about
playing the penguin in the batman movie
i've been spoken to him since but i'm
really looking
forward to it i i
i think that uh uh no matter what he's
gonna be
great because he's a great actor and uh
uh the only thing he has to worry about
is that oswald cobblepot will show up at
his house